but why you need to be with me here okay
you my name is Jacob sorry that's a lie
hi my name is Sean hi my name is Asia
and we're doing never have I ever lying
edition never have I ever lied about
where I was or where I was going to my
parents I don't I don't I don't think I
had no like they gave me freedom like
they trusted me so they didn't really
like ask where I was going in is he's
never taken advantage of that it was a
couple times I may have taken advantage
but they didn't ask so it wasn't a lot
hmm never have I ever lied to a teacher
about why I couldn't turn in my homework
[Music]
what square are you if you haven't lied
about this once stupid white lies like I
lost the homework or I didn't see the
homework really I probably like fell
asleep it's sad enough that I have a
go-to life but my go-to is family
emergency just because you know it my
drawers out emmab it draws out empathy
you know they kind of want to be there
for you no I'm not attracting that
energy person because unless something
actually happened like the number of
times I've said family emergencies you
would think that there's something
really wrong with you never have I ever
lied about what I was doing on social
media so I think I have I mean that's
kind of a vague question so I'm just
gonna go with I have to be safe I'm
gonna say I have not
I don't recall I don't like how many
social media it's like just for being
fake anyways though never have I ever
lied about why I showed up late who
hasn't done it was not do like like for
real well you think in our day and age
we could be punctual no I don't know
about that never have I ever told my
friends or family that I liked something
or someone that I actually did it you
know you do things to spare people's
feelings yes look lying it's not about
hurting someone it's about protecting
oh no I'm not condoning it I'm not going
to the end of this video I'll make you a
believer never have I ever lied about my
relationship status why you need to be
with me here okay you know I feel like
in the long run it's just easier it's
just easier less questions asked also my
parents everything just sounds like
excuse they really like pry in so I just
like to you know how am i answering
questions so I would rather with the
simplicity not the truth that's what
should ever believe anything you ever
say never have I ever been caught in a
big lie and being called out once was a
big lie I think the biggest lie I can
think of I got caught for was I was
taking Chinese in college my roommate at
the time was Chinese and so for the
whole semester he would do my audio
recording homeworks and I would get
hundreds on these and then on the last
week the professor called on me to go up
and do one like yeah that's not a good
day she pulled me aside after classes
she was like okay so you know these are
supposed to be done individually right
that's like no
smells kind of embarrassing I feel like
I feel like maybe I would tell like some
guys that I love them but I didn't
that's a way bigger lie never have I
ever been ashamed of a lie I told
honestly I feel I feel shitty anytime I
live because I don't like lying I'm not
good at lying I have like like my
conscience is like why are you saying
that I'm just telling my son because
also probably I on the other hand I've
only been ashamed at a poor execution of
the lie I told someone has no remorse
you know what if you're if you're a liar
just embrace it never have I ever lied
to convince someone to do something for
me oh my god everyone has hey I'm not
feeling well can you go grab this for me
hey I've never done that
what never have I ever taken money from
my parents wallet without asking you've
never done this no I've literally never
done this that's messed up no one sent
this video it's my parents please you
know sometimes you just need a five or a
ten yeah but it's their money in a mine
never have I ever lied to impress
someone I literally have been talking
about this the whole time I mean
hopefully I'm not like that anymore but
but when you have like low self-esteem
it's like all right how do I get this
person to like me and people do this in
real life everyday everywhere huh yeah
do people not shoes do this in real life
everywhere don't you know I mean
sometimes sometimes you have to know you
never have to it's a choice never have I
lied to my parents about my reason for
moving across the country just
have I flipped my paddle once this whole
game why did you lie about this I had
the condensed version was my parents are
pretty protective and I want to move out
to LA but I didn't have a job so I told
them I had an unpaid internship for six
months
and then they would hire me full-time so
in those six months I was looking for
jobs but did they ever find out about
this know they have it probably not
until they watch this video so yeah no I
mean you're employed now yeah that's
yeah yeah no it's okay well Sean was
saying he's a lawyer so I'm not
surprised about anything
you know what look if you're a liar just
embrace it or or it's not buying look
there are so many situations that end
better when you lie I look what what
situation why did I do this chuckles I
just lie it's lime or no don't lie do
not listen to him please
[Music]